bienvenidos en este vídeo voy a analizar
la regla del producto para derivadas sin
embargo también voy a utilizar
conocimiento de la regla de la cadena
que ya habíamos visto que nos dice la
regla del producto para derivadas bueno
primero voy a escribir la regla o la
teoría en general y después vamos a ver
algunos ejemplos para que les quede
mucho más claro estas reglas mucho más
sencilla que el anterior y dice que si f
x es una función hdx que a su vez
multiplica a otra función llamada g de x
es decir f x es una multiplicación de
funciones por eso es la regla del
producto quién va a ser mi derivada de
fx esa va a ser la pregunta de esta vez
y bueno la formulita dice que la
derivada de fx es tomen la primera
función y derive la y después
multiplique la por la segunda función
sin derivar y a esto súmele la primera
función sin derivar y multiplicado por
la derivada de la segunda función aquí
está la regla del producto esta es la
regla con la que vamos a trabajar
este vídeo entonces espero que se
deshaga muy fácil así que tomemos un
ejemplo para que quede mucho más claro
no voy a tomar que fx es igual y voy a
poner una multiplicación de funciones
voy a tomar el 5x elevado a la quinta
menos x a las 7 y estos dos términos
estarán multiplicando su vez a 20 x al
cuadrado más 3 veces x al menos 7 muy
bien y seguramente lo primero que van a
pensar es que nosotros podemos
multiplicar cada uno de los términos de
este binomio por cada uno de los
términos del otro binomio sin embargo si
nosotros utilizamos la regla de la
cadena tal vez esta derivada es mucho
más fácil que primero multiplicar todos
contra todos
entonces utilizamos la regla de la
cadena dice primero deriva la primera
función y la derivada de la primera
función es muy sencilla es 25 x a la
cuarta y a esto le quitamos 7 veces x a
la sexta muy bien ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la segunda función tal
cual sin derivar por eso lo voy a
cambiar de color y voy a poner la
segunda función
sin derivar igualita 20 x al cuadrado
más 3x a la menos 7 ok pero hasta aquí
vamos a la mitad de la regla del
producto nos falta la otra mitad y la
otra mitad dice tome la segunda función
y derive la entonces vamos a derivar la
segunda función que nos queda la
derivada de 20 x cuadrada pues es 20 por
2 que es 40 x y la derivada de más 3 x a
la menos 7 es menos 21 x a la menos 8 en
un 7 menos unos menos 8 y después
multiplique la por la primera función
sin derivar así como ésta es decir 5
veces x a la 5 - x a las 7 y ya está así
de fácil es la derivada por la regla del
producto es decir tomen la primera
función de nivelar y multiplica la por
la segunda función ya esto agréguele la
derivada de la segunda función que
multiplica a la primera función es así
de fácil y de sencillo así que vamos a
hacer otros ejemplos que prueben
a esta regla bien borremos el pizarrón y
pongamos uno nuevo y ahora me voy a
tomar una función y otra vez un par de
funciones sencillas para ir calentando
para llegar al ejemplo difícil bien
entonces voy a tomar la función y la voy
a poner aquí fx es igual am
y entonces tomemos una multiplicación de
funciones que va a ser f x pues va a ser
10 x al cubo ya esto le voy a sumar 5
veces x cuadrada ya esto le voy a restar
7 y todo esto lo voy a multiplicar por
20 x adoptaba menos 7 es una
multiplicación de funciones entonces
tomemos la regla del producto que dice
tomemos la primera función y derivamos
la es decir la derivada de 10 x cúbica
es 30 x cuadrada la derivada de 5x
cuadrada es 10x y pues la derivada de 7
se va es una constante y después
multipliquemos lo por la otra función
sin derivar igual y está muy bien ya
esto hay que agregarle pues la derivada
de la segunda expresión
segunda función entonces hagamos la la
derivada de 20 x 8ª es 160 x a la 7 y la
derivada de 7 será por lo tanto
solamente nos queda 160 x elevado a las
7 que multiplica quien a la primera
función tal cual sin derivar ya no es
necesario hacer nada 10x cubica más 5x
cuadrada menos 7 y ya está tenemos por
la regla del producto la derivada de fx
muy bien realmente no está tan difícil
esto es una cosa muy sencilla de hacer y
de hecho también podríamos reducir estas
funciones que tenemos aquí multiplicando
las cada uno por la otra sin embargo
estos parlamentos que habrá de ccoo
entonces mejor vamos hacer otro ejemplo
y en este ejemplo voy a juntar la regla
del producto y la regla de la cadena por
lo tanto al acabar este vídeo
seguramente van a estar lo
suficientemente confundidos como para
tener la intención de volver a ver el
vídeo para que les quede mucho más claro
recuerdan que pueden ver los vídeos
cuantas veces sea necesario para que
poco a poco les vaya quedando mucho más
claro lo que estamos haciendo
esto es voy a tomar iguala x cuadrada 2x
esto ha llevado a las 5 que multiplica
todo esto a su vez a 3x al menos 3 ya
esto le voy a sumar a x cuadrada muy
bien y esto elevado a la menos 7 wow se
ve hasta ahorita bastante divertida pero
lo que sí quiero que vean es que es una
multiplicación de funciones simple
sencillamente es una multiplicación de
funciones ahora sí calculemos la
derivada de y con respecto a x o la
primera derivada de esta función y quién
va a ser bueno primero tenemos una
función aquí lo voy a atrapar con otro
color para que para que no sea todo
amarillo esta función que tengo aquí es
una función que a su vez está elevada a
la quinta potencia entonces para derivar
la quinta potencia tenemos que utilizar
la regla de la cadena que decía que
derivamos primero lo que está dentro la
derivada de x cuadrada más 2x es 2 x + 2
muy bien y después bajábamos el
exponente 5 que multiplica a una función
y esto elevado a 45 menos 1
y la función que estaba dentro de la
función tal cual es cuadrada + 2 sin
hacerle nada ojo ya estamos calculando
la derivada de la primera función y como
la regla del producto me dice derivada
la primera función y multiplicada por la
segunda función sin derivar entonces
vamos a multiplicarlo por 3x menos 3 más
x cuadrada elevado a la menos 7 sin
derivar sin hacer nada y después la
regla del producto me dice a esto
sumarle la derivada de la segunda
función entonces vamos a calcular la
derivada de la segunda función que si
ustedes se dan cuenta esta derivada
también es por regla de la cadena
entonces lo voy a hacer con verde y voy
a tomar esta derivada y quien va a hacer
pues primero tenemos que derivar lo que
está dentro del paréntesis es decir
menos 3 x 3 9 y es x a la menos 4 porque
menos tres menos unos cuatro y la
derivada de x cuadradas 2x y todo esto
hay que multiplicarlo por quien bajamos
el menos siete ponemos un paréntesis y
le bajamos una la potencia menos siete
menos unos menos 8
adentro del paréntesis ponemos la
función tal cual sin derivar 3x a la
menos 3 + x cuadrada muy bien ya todo
esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
primera función no se les olvide todavía
no hemos acabado a todo eso hay que
multiplicarlo por la primera función que
teníamos en nuestra multiplicación de
funciones es decir x cuadrada más 2 x
elevado a la quinta y ahora si ya
acabamos esta derivada por la regla del
producto y utilizando también la regla
de la cadena y aunque esto pareció muy
enredado realmente no lo era tanto
porque si nosotros teníamos el primer
binomio y lo elevamos a la quinta
potencia y después lo multiplicamos por
el segundo binomio elevado a la menos
séptima potencia y va a ser muy largo
casi eterno entonces la regla del
producto y la regla de la cadena nos
sirvió bastante además espero que
ustedes se acuerden cuál era la
expresión geométrica de la derivada la
expresión geométrica de la derivada era
la pendiente de la recta tangente
asociada a algún punto de mi función y
con esta derivada ya lo obtuvimos en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a analizar
funciones pero que ya no sean polinomios
tal vez
o métricas exponenciales logarítmicas
pero eso será en el siguiente vídeo y
con más reglas nos vemos